salut Steve ici aujourd'hui c'est une
vidéo bilingue c'est une
vidéo impromptue parce que la vidéo belanger
tire un poème Monsieur Etienne folk tango
Chi c'est un journaliste qui travaille pour
une organisation ou au moins a fourni une
vidéo pour Nord une organisation appelée
om fr qui est moi  crois que je ne sais pas
ce que signifie Oh et fr mais c'est une
organisation qui promeut le bilinguisme
ou le français plutôt dans la province de l'
Ontario et il a mis en place une
vidéo dont je laisserai un lien vers où il
prétend qu'il y a un groupe de  les gens qui
s'opposaient encore une fois au bilinguisme comme
si c'était quelque chose de très mal, c'est-
à-dire s'opposer au bilinguisme est mal et il
me jette là-dedans comme l'une des personnes
opposées au bilinguisme et prend un
petit extrait d'une vidéo que j'ai faite
contre le gouvernement  déchets et il
me cite leur disant que la
déclaration de notre premier ministre selon
laquelle vous connaissez la langue des
groupes minoritaires au Canada est vitale pour le
Canada ou quelque chose et  J'ai fait remarquer
que ce n'est pas vrai, c'est juste du fluff en
fait, c'est bien si les gens veulent apprendre le
français, ils doivent être motivés pour le
faire s'ils font partie d'une
communauté francophone et de la Saskatchewan Alberta et
s'ils sont motivés pour maintenir leur
langage qui est formidable, ils devraient le faire,
mais ils ne sont en aucun cas vitaux pour le Canada
, alors oh et je dois également souligner
que c'est très important en ce jour
où nous avons des gouvernements comme le
gouvernement de m.  Trump danse partout où
je suis en ce moment aux États-Unis et
ailleurs en criant toujours de fausses nouvelles à
chaque fois qu'une nouvelle sort qui leur est en
quelque sorte défavorable ou si un
journaliste a une opinion qui leur est
défavorable, elle est présentée comme une
fausse nouvelle c'est très  important que les
journalistes fassent attention à ne pas déformer
ce que les gens ont à dire pour ne pas sortir les
choses de leur contexte
et et vous savez que ma propre expérience a
été que très souvent les journalistes
se trompent, mais de plus en plus de journalistes
retournent à la source et disent est-ce dans
en fait ce que vous avez dit avez-vous dit c'est
ce que vous vouliez dire essayez de confirmer que
ce qu'ils rapportent est exact je
pense que cela va devenir très
précis très important parce que je
crois que nous avons besoin des médias je pense que les médias
sont un élément vital  de notre démocratie mais les
acteurs des médias eux-mêmes doivent être
responsables
bo officier Monsieur pour Taguchi húsavík
inclure Buzzelli luma être présent une
vidéo de Dom Lovato come kalca Kato Paseo de la
misma Jennifer di dama vidéo dans Donna
ferry a coulé un chaud mil de sus frais une
vidéo vidéo YouTube par semaine un nouveau
para s chimie extrême a contra la
méchant Wisma amarre un train Marinette
développe notre demande fait un groupe jacques
certains s'opposent à un noble abyssal sûr le plus  c'est
opposer un halètement Pierre de la August PR
les dollars et un contributeur pauvre le
programme les phénomènes comparent exemple la
la plantation fallodon gocanada Kiva
Cote du sang million dollar sucess a
dole paneer argentin Appa Otto Peto
mammal education copier certains halètements
Pierre Jean Jean  Pascal à La Jolla
Google ma fédéral de la lluvia rocheux
d'un kanuto la langue B plus Québec
Vermont une maladie de vous verrez des taches sur les
Juifs KCCI vous déclencherez de pauvres
efforts
suzka la la n'a qu'à penser Chaka Khan
Madonna dr.  Tanaka Verano pasado de
possible membre de Donna paulbyrne a dit
période butin Oh double angoisse du Québec
AFET ceci sous les services de la fonction publique
ne dans un présent probablement des
effets hmmm à Uralla a
mis la situation Pascoe
Pascal de casandra angoisse mobile MA Satan Cassio
personnel voir mm lopata Sultanahmet  en
question la motivation voir et le mal
émotif un mal sur nous un mal sur
Travis Santa cetera la grappa vous gamma
un motif simple un lol muhaha pas de
communauté idiote Falco téléphoner une Alberta
Saskatchewan Ville Monténégro même pas
juste - Raja yoga pose un rire une
responsabilité de cola  la la compétence
non-calcul Aswath dit personnel ne
double pas super contre être la langue homme juste
être le contrôle halète Pierre DeVaughn public
a considérer les partis de couleur sont le candidat
n'appartient pas Wisma d'accord Beck d'accord Beck
deuxième question la décision décision personnelle
et parc de l'ozone  Rosario c'est
pas le le laasa parties du corps Ikaruga Akiva
co2 un instructeur de conception et est une
étiquette ou att  itudes du programme
fabrication de douches
affaire de podracers le nevada bielagus mo
canada un travail sera le nouveau pas de
tournay
idée effrayante dans le présent a venir Kelkar
un OD s'il vous plaît la position qu'ils ont probablement
choisie une pop d'accord
voila le bon travail de la ville eid merci ora
[  La musique]